hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Lisa
mihalick come on Tara do that sexy voice
you got okay
Kanye West steams up don't ask me about
Wiz beef presented from my favorite
television series TMZ nothing is funnier
than when people harass celebrities
trust me
Tyrone and I get it all the time yeah
paparazzi just everywhere my paparazzi's
different cuz I usually like it informed
my publicist like where I'm eating like
pit viper like some cameras there and I
may be like Oh
leave me alone I don't want to be
[ __ ] bothered right now but it makes
me look humble you know I got my own
personal life but I really don't all
right guys
enough talking let's watch
[Music]
was that wage Kanye was that wife's much
that's why you saying that some I love
it man
hey he's treating you in a bit harder
with this morning
[Music]
did you go be harmony I said what I had
to say I say that he was a bit much
bringing the kid into a day I've told
you I said I said all I had to say oh I
have no more questions about some dummy
where you take so much time and
appreciate you thank you I'm Charlie
Charlie I'm a good man yeah I didn't
mean to talk to you heavy after that
show respect to you your family it's all
you got man thank you so much not the
Kanye I know he is watching his behavior
yeah wait what did he say to Wiz does
anyone know he said what he had to say
that's all he said in the video the man
they ate I love that [ __ ] like it was
gonna be some extremes the backstory and
all the tweets here Kanye West
yeah I just want to see the Twitter
tracking is an ex-girlfriend by scoffing
a whisper getting trapped by a stripper
wow that's pretty mean for such a
dickish thing he really handled the
paparazzi thing rather well yeah he was
really respectful to the guy yeah I
think the guy who's harassing him and
outlast or something yeah like I think I
think Carney is trying to make a better
impression of himself I think he's
really going out there to really tie
runs a huge fan of of Kanye every day
he's like I'm like Tyrone song so old
stop singing it that's like the only
Connie a song you know he's got to I'm
saying gia gold digger but she ain't
messing with no broke Tyrone
say the word lead or you're the only one
who could see it in this room right now
Victoria would say Victoria might say
well we establishes Victoria is that the
sexual beast inside of Lisa like I was
trying to tell Lisa
earlier but she's never seen the movie
it's kind of like x-men 3 how Jean Grey
Phoenix inside of her and she's been
like bottling up Phoenix for so long
that and then we'll rings like you cage
the beast long enough beast will get
angry and implying the beast will break
out what Victoria is her Phoenix good
Kanye West Kanye West has got to be one
of the most hey guys hey I'm trying to
make the video relevant right now yeah
you gonna stop this alright alright deep
wait she did Kanye West is seriously one
of the biggest douche bags I've ever
heard of and I really hope he doesn't
hear this video because I'm afraid he's
gonna like rip me apart cuz you know I
can only talk [ __ ] about him like behind
his back you know what sucks is he seems
like such a dick in real life but I
really do like his songs like I actually
get into it's music you know I'm like
man this guy's a dick but but does he
make some cool songs and that's what
really matters at the end of the day I
guess except in some situations Chris
Brown I don't think he deserves a career
sang it's pretty [ __ ] up what that guy
did why can't we forget Mel Gibson I'm
really honest Mel Gibson did not do
anything as bad as Chris Brown it's all
in perspective Chris Brown doing when I
go answer it and Wiz Khalifa I think I
feel like Wiz Khalifa is hated on a lot
already you know yes you know what's
Khalifa do you you know that is I do
know that is Miss Khalifa don't mind
well yeah I know I know everyone Wiz
Khalifa I've heard he's been getting
like ever since the [ __ ] uh was that
Paul Paul Walker song see you again yeah
no keep going everything every time I
like watch the music video there's so
many comments are like Wiz Khalifa ruins
the song and it was like such a [ __ ]
huge song called see you again yeah oh
yeah yeah it's not they say that enough
[Music]
and they I did that was [ __ ]
hilarious you guys that's great great
material as I was trying to like
actually remember something relevant you
guys were just talking and talking
I'm sorry guys I've been very moody this
past 10 minutes it really escalate
very bad Kanye for example right right
like insulting Wiz Khalifa yeah it's his
ex-girlfriend Wiz's ex-girlfriend don't
have to do that like why like why
suddenly include hey we're talking about
Amber Rose Amber Rose yeah what would is
she do that's so wrong what she did tell
me why would he just go after the
ex-girlfriend it's like if someone was
like it's like you were getting mad at
me
and then you're getting mad at me about
like my ex-girlfriend who I'm no longer
involved with or no that's like that's
not cool like what's he doing that's why
is he always tearing people down when he
doesn't need to be why Kanye I just a
thief I just stay out of it
I don't know the relationship like I
think Mike Epps said it best when you
still not Chris Brown and Rihanna and he
said hey why y'all keep taking her side
you don't know what that big
Frankenstein hit it [ __ ] did to him
Ryan didn't find his body dark sense of
humor sometimes I don't believe in dark
humor like that you know sometimes the
one thing is really put in the forefront
there's like a side to every story right
it was right that he hit her I heard a
story that said that she had given him
something Oh
and that's why flip them I'm not saying
it's right gonorrhea HIV her pearly or
at least me I shouldn't make fun of
people with herpes one third of the
subscribers on the real rejects have
herpes I'm sorry herpes based audience
let's just take a moment to admire her
oh sorry
brace Victoria too much because Victoria
is wrong aggressive things risks Lisa I
would feel excited if I knew I'd be
included in the threesome however I know
they don't want me oh my god okay it's
just a waste of time for me here
my man Ryan right no I can't be in the
yeah okay I wasn't about you yes listen
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe my room magnesite has a
channel called Tyrone Magnus if you
haven't heard of his channel that's very
hard for me to believe because most of
you are yeah I'm trying to close out the
video I have to edit this [ __ ] and you
guys are just like check out Tyrone's
channel lisa has an Instagram yes where
it's plenty of photos of her claim to
fame is nowhere present Wow
really you didn't send me a fellow pizza